seit fast einem Jahrhundert
interpretieren Meinungsforscher die
öffentliche
Meinung möchten Sie an einer Umfrage zur
bevorstehenden Wahl teilnehmen ihre
Methode ist einfach sie stellen einer
kleinen Gruppe von Personen Fragen und
verwenden diese Stichprobe dann als
Repräsentant für die Meinung der
gesamten Bevölkerung vielen Dank Sir es
war schön Sie kennenzulernen nun gern
geschehen gute Nacht danke dass sie da
waren doch in den letzten Jahrzehnten
hat die Öffentlichkeit keine Lust mehr
Fragen Anrufe oder Türklingeln zu
beantworten und die Menschen sind nicht
mehr nur an einem einzigen Ort
erreichbar sondern zunehmend mobil
geworden das macht traditionelle
Umfragen zu einer größeren
Herausforderung heutzutage äußern die
Menschen ihre Meinungen und Gewohnheiten
über mobil und Internettechnologien
inklusive Smartphones und soziale Medien
diese informationslawine ermöglicht neue
Methoden zu erforschen was die
Öffentlichkeit denkt
[Musik]
heute sind Daten überall
verfügbar Kreditkarteninformationen
kundenkarteninformationen demographische
Informationen und Informationen von
gemeinschaftsorganisationen denken Sie
an die Dinge für die sie sich anmelden
denken Sie an die Veranstaltungen die
Sie besuchen und wenn Sie auf das kleine
Kästchen klicken wo daneben steht ich
habe die Nutzungsbedingungen gelesen und
stimme ihnen zu dann ist das ein Vertrag
mehrere Seiten mit Sachen die sie sich
nicht durchgelesen haben die niemand
liest und es wäre auch egal wenn sie es
durchlesen würden das bedeutet dass wir
Informationen aus allen Teilen der Welt
erhalten und genau das macht sie so
wertvoll viele Menschen geben Google
ihre e-mailaten über Gmail ihre
Videodaten über Youtube und ihren
Aufenthaltsort über Google Maps wenn man
also all diese Daten miteinander
verknüpft ist es bemerkenswert welch
intimes Bild es von einer Person
zeichnet das meiner Meinung nach unser
eigenes Gedächtnis in den Schatten
stellt und dass uns all die Orte
vergessen lässt an denen wir
waren die Herausforderung besteht darin
aus einem scheinbar zufälligen Rauschen
aussagekräftige Informationen zu
extrahieren die angewandte künstliche
Intelligenz auch KI genannt birgt hier
sowohl Chancen als auch
Risiken während das topische Science
Fiction von Welten träumt in denen
Maschinen über Menschen herrschen
verstehen ihre Ingenieure KI eher als
eine Maschine die lernen und denken
kann sie betrachten sie als ein vom
Menschen gelenktes Werkzeug das lernt
indem es riesige Datenmengen z.B aus
sozialen Medien verarbeitet und dann
Muster im Rauschen erkennt was wäre wenn
es eine KI gäbe die anhand dieser Muster
vorhersagen könnte wie sich Menschen in
der Zukunft verhalten z.B um den Ausgang
einer Wahl
vorherzusagen der Wahlkampf für die
nächsten kanadischen bundeswahlen hat
soeben begonnen während Premierminister
Justin Trudeau liberale Partei mit einem
Justizskandal und der Entlassung von
zwei Ministern zu tun hat haben die
Konservativen die neuen Demokraten und
der blockbequis alle neue und unerprobte
Führer trotz eines knappen sechswöchigen
Wahlkampfes haben die Parteien nur
langsam ihre Programme vorgestellt es
ist unklar ob die Wähler Ihre Wahl auf
der Grundlage der Themen der Partei oder
der Spitzenkandidaten Treffen werden in
Kanadas Hauptstadt Ottawa nutzt ein
kleines Startup KI um die bevorstehenden
Wahlen
vorherzusagen die Leute nennen das die
sefeldwahl wirklich weil es um nichts
geht ja obwohl das bei jeder Wahl so ist
ich glaube es ist eher das G Teil der
Fall um ehrlich zu sein die Leute haben
zu mir gesagt dass dies die erste Wahl
ist bei der sie tatsächlich auf die
Politik schauen und nicht auf die
Spitzenkandidaten die beiden
Spitzenkandidaten bedeuten mir nichts es
geht wirklich darum wer meiner Meinung
nach die beste Arbeit leisten wird für
die Wirtschaft für die Umwelt und wisst
ihr ich habe viele Leute sagen hören
dass die Wirtschaft natürlich für Sie an
erster Stelle steht aber wer hat die
beste Politik der Physiker Kenton white
und die Buchhalterin aon Kelly haben
2015 advanced symbolics asi
mitbegründet das
Marktforschungsunternehmen nutzt
öffentliche Daten und künstliche
Intelligenz um die Einstellung der
Verbraucher zu prognostizieren wisst ihr
in Zeiten von Cambridge analytica und
alldem denken die Leute dass es sich um
eine Art voodowissenschaft handelt als
ob wir einen Schamanen hätten der Dinge
geschehen lässt ich möchte dass die
Leute verstehen dass es nur um
Mathematik geht Wissenschaft es ist
probabilistisch es ist Statistik so wie
es schon immer war nur dass die Daten
von Poly und nicht von Telefonisten
erhoben werden
sie können einen ähnlichen Ansatz
verwenden um politische Meinungen
vorherzusagen früher war es schwierig
Informationen über Millionen und
Abermillionen von Menschen zu erhalten
und darauf statistische Physik
anzuwenden aber jetzt habe ich Facebook
jetzt habe ich Twitter wie kann ich das
nutzen obwohl sie weder für politische
Parteien noch für Nachrichtenagenturen
Arbeiten sahen Kelly und White das
wahlvorhersagespiel als eine Möglichkeit
ihre Forschungsmethode zu bewerben
denken Sie daran wie oft wir uns bei der
traditionellen Marktforschung in das
Thema in die Menschen einmischen während
wir sie untersuchen wir mischen uns ein
indem wir sie zur Teilnahme auffordern
wir mischen uns in das Ergebnis ein
indem wir eine Frage stellen und wie wir
diese Frage formulieren unsere Idee war
dass die sozialen Medien eine großartige
Möglichkeit bieten Menschen in ihrer
natürlichen Umgebung zu beobachten und
werden Sie nicht eine viel bessere
Politik und eine viel utopischere
Gesellschaft erreichen wenn Sie genau
wissen was die Menschen in dieser
Gesellschaft
wollen als ich aufwuchs inspirierte mich
die Science Fiction zumb Asimovs
Foundation Reihe in der man die Physik
und die statistische Physik auf Menschen
und Populationen anwenden und den
gesamten Verlauf der Galaxie abbilden
kann ich war ziemlich enttäuscht als ich
erfuhr dass das nicht wirklich möglich
ist die explosionsartige Zunahme der
Daten in den sozialen Medien bot white
eine potenzielle fundgobe er konnte
der Physik anwenden um Daten zu
verarbeiten die anderen als
unübersichtlich und unbrauchbar
erscheinen
mögen das war die Geburtsstunde der KI
die ASI Po
nennt Po war die Abkürzung für Politik
also haben wir sie einfach so genannt
wir haben uns da keine geden dar gemer
ebenk standteilen kleinen Programm die
das Internet durchforsten und
Informationen
sammeln diese Programme die Algorithmen
genannt werden sind eine Reihe von
Anweisungen zur Durchführung einer
bestimmten
Aufgabe sie haben einen Algorithmus der
bestimmt wann sie jemanden auswählen und
wann nicht kleine Algorithmen die diese
Person analysieren und zu dem Schluss
kommen ob die Person männlich oder
weiblich reich oder arm jung oder alt
Schwarz oder Weiß ist men die es uns
ermöglichen Menschen zu finden die über
das Thema sprechen das wir messen
[Musik]
wollen wenn ich ihnen einen dieser
Algorithmen zeigen würde und wie er
funktioniert würden sie wahrscheinlich
sagen das ist doch ganz
einfach erst wenn man Dutzende und
aberdutzende nimmt und all diese Dinge
zusammenfügt entsteht etwas
komplexeres sie verwendet mehr Daten als
ich oder sie oder so ziemlich jeder hier
in einem Leben verstehen könnte
[Musik]
aber was macht Polly intelligent
beachten Sie dass ich nicht
empfindungsfähig sondern intelligent
gesagt habe richtig sie ist also
intelligent weil sie Konzepte begreifen
kann mathematische Konzepte und weil sie
Muster in Menschen erkennt die wir
selbst nicht sehen können doch diese
Beschreibung bereitet den Kritikern der
KI Unbehagen die KI Methode wirkt auf
Außenstehende wie eine Blackbox sass es
für nicht K schwierig ist das Innenleben
der KI oder ihre Schlussfolgerungen zu
hinterfragen angesichts der Skeptiker
sah asi das brexit Referendum im Juni
2016 als eine Möglichkeit ihren
algoritthmus zu
testen die Bürger des Vereinigten
Königreichs stimmten darüber ab ob sie
in der Europäischen Union bleiben oder
sie verlassen wollen die traditionell
fast täglich durchgeführten Umfragen
zeigten dass das Land gespalten war je
näher der Wahltag rückte desto klarer
wurde dass die unentschlossenen Wähler
wahrscheinlich über das Schicksal des
Landes entscheiden
[Musik]
würden in der Zwischenzeit hat Poly die
britischen twitterdaten durchforstet um
die Meinungen der Nutzer vorherzusagen
ohne sie direkt zu
kontaktieren Poly war bis drei Tage vor
dem eigentlichen Referendum für den
Verbleib
bei uns haben 52% für den Verbleib und
48% für den Austritt gestimmt so wie
jeder andere auf der Welt auch dann kam
die Ermordung von Joe
Cox die Abgeordnete der laborpartei Joe
Cox die sich für den Verbleib im
Parlament eingesetzt hatte wurde am 16
Juni 2016 von einem Rechtsextremisten
erschossen drei Tage vor dem Referendum
wachen wir auf schauen auf Poly und
plötzlich will Großbritannien die EU
verlassen das war etwas anderes als das
was Sie an jedem anderen Tag der Woche
und während des gesamten Wahlkampfs
gesagt
hatte ich war besorgt denn ein Attentat
ist ein schwarzer Schwan ein schwarzer
Schwan ist ein seltenes Ereignis eines
das meine KI noch nie zuvor gesehen hat
und bei keiner der Wahlen auf die ich
sie trainiert hatte gab es ein Attentat
Attentate sind selten wir haben ihr also
gesagt sie soll die Ermordung von Joe
Cox ignorieren was ist das Ergebnis
bleiben also testen wir es noch einmal
Joe Cox wird ermordet austreten was hat
sich also geändert was hat sie gesehen
was alle anderen auf der Welt übersehen
haben das britische Pfund stürzte auf
ein 30 Jahrestief und die weltweiten
Aktienmärkte erschütterte die Nachricht
dass die Mehrheit der britischen Wähler
den Austritt aus der Europäischen Union
der zweitgrößten Volkswirtschaft der
Welt
wünscht Poly beobachtet Dinge von denen
wir nicht einmal denken würden dass sie
sie beobachtet wir haben sie nicht darum
gebeten diese Dinge zu beobachten nun
wir sind alles durchgegangen David
Cameron hatte in dieser Zeit viele
Pressekonferenzen gegeben und es gab
eine Sache die er gesagt hat es ist
richtig dass wir die wahlkampftätigkeit
für dieses Referendum aussetzen und
jedermanns Gedanken sind in dieser
schrecklichen Zeit bei Jo Familie und
bei ihren Wählern während des ganzen
Jahres indem sie die Menschen
beobachtete stellte sie fest dass
Menschen die Online sagten ich denke
darüber nach für einen Austritt zu
stimmen ein Netzwerk von Freunden und
Familienmitgliedern um Sicherung
die Ihnen in aller Ruhe erklärten warum
wir für einen Verbleib stimmen sollten
und was die Konsequenzen wären mit der
Zeit gelang es diesem Netzwerk diese
Menschen für den Verbleib zu gewinnen
sofern sie den Dialog aufrech
erhielten aber wenn die Leute nicht mehr
miteinander reden würde ein gewisser
Prozentsatz dieser unentschlossenen auf
der Grundlage dessen was Polly in der
Vergangenheit festgestellt hatte
austreten also wandte sie diesen
Algorithmus an sie hat es genau
getroffen besser zu verstehen ist es
hilfreich sich anzuschauen was sie mit
traditionellen Umfragen gemeinsam
hat eine Möglichkeit die öffentliche
Meinung zu erheben sind Befragungen
kurze Interviews werden als Umfragen
bezeichnet einige wenige Personen werden
sorgfältig als Stichproben der
wichtigsten Gruppen der allgemeinen
Öffentlichkeit ausgewählt jahrzehntelang
erreichten die Meinungsforscher die
Menschen erfolgreich über
Festnetzanschlüsse Direktwerbung oder
das klop an Türen die Rücklaufquote lag
bei 80% alle Anrufe gingen ins Festnetz
es gab keine Handys und die Leute
liebten ess an Umfragen teilzunehmen
wenn man sich bei einer Wahl irrt ist
das so als würde man aus einem Boot
fallen und das Wasser
verfehlen das ist das dritte klopfen und
im Haus sieht dunkel aus ja niemand zu
Hause doch in den letzten 30 Jahren sind
die Nutzung von Festnetzanschlüssen und
die Rücklaufquote von Umfragen stark
zurückgegangen wenn Sie einen
Festnetzanschluss in einem beliebigen
Haus anrufen ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit
groß dass sie eine ältere Frau erreichen
Millennials erreichen Sie nicht über das
Festnetz wahrscheinlich werden Sie sie
über Mobiltelefone erreichen oder
online traditionelle Meinungsforscher
mussten ihre Methoden diversifizieren um
verschiedene Zielgruppen zu
erreichen man versucht den politischen
Markt den wichtigen politischen Markt
und die wählende Bevölkerung so genau
wie möglich zu
repräsentieren was man also braucht ist
eine gute Abdeckung all dieser
verschiedenen Bevölkerungsgruppen und
dann versucht man sie in ihrer
Gesamtheit zu
betrachten um die kanadische Bevölkerung
im Jahr 2019 zu erfassen kombiniert der
Meinungsforscher Daryl Bricker Umfragen
im Festnetz mit Umfragen per Handy und
online Umfragen doch die KI von pouli
geht einen anderen Weg da unsere
Bevölkerung immer vielfältiger wird
brauchen wir eigentlich eine größere
Stichprobe ich meine Kanada ist heute
ganz anders als 1970 oder
1959 als wir mit der Telefonumfrage
begannen aber wir haben die Wissenschaft
seit den 50er Jahren nicht wirklich
weiterentwickelt wir haben immer noch
die gleichen Stichproben Größen wir
gehen immer noch auf dieselbe Weise an
die Wissenschaft heran auch wenn sich
die Bevölkerung stark verändert hat mit
den sozialen Medien haben wir nun
endlich die Möglichkeit diese
Wissenschaft zum ersten Mal seit 50
Jahren weiter zu
entwickeln traditionelle
Meinungsumfragen haben in letzter Zeit
mehrere Wahlergebnisse mit ihren
Prognosen verfehlt wir werden das Weiße
Haus gewinnen wir werden es Rück erobern
vielleicht am bekanntesten bei den
US-Präsidentschaftswahlen 2016 sagten
die Meinungsforscher mit überwältigender
Mehrheit voraus dass Hillary Clinton
Donald Trump schlagen würde wenn die
Schlangen morgen lang sind warten sie
[Musik]
bitte Trump Sieg hat gezeigt dass die
Meinungsforscher ihr Ziel verfehlt haben
sie sagten zwar die Volksabstimmung
voraus verpassten aber die Knappen
lokalen Rennen in den swingstates die
Trump einen Sieg im Electoral College
bescherten offensichtlich lagen ihre
Modelle einfach völlig daneben der in
den Umfragen vorhergesagte Prozentsatz
der Stimmen ist tatsächlich eingetreten
aber wir haben nicht das Electoral
College
gemessen natürlich ist das ein Albtraum
wenn so etwas
passiert während es zu kostspielig und
ineffizient wäre regelmäßig große
Befragungen mit herkömmlichen Methoden
durchzuführen ist dies dank der enormen
Reichweite der sozialen Medien mit Hilfe
von KI möglich sozialen Medien über
Politik zu sprechen oder alle Meinungen
in den sozialen Medien zu äußern ist
heute so etwas wie die Norm das ist zu
einer normalen Art der Kommunikation
geworden so wie die Leute früher auch
häufig lange Gespräche am Telefon
geführt haben natürlich konnte man
früher nicht einfach die Telefone der
Leute Abhören man musste sie anrufen und
nach ihrer Meinung fragen aber jetzt ist
das interessante an den sozialen Medien
dass die Leute ihre Meinung über die
sozialen Medien mitteilen oft tun sie
das in einer Form die öffentlich ist und
die es uns ermögllich zu sehen was sie
sagen und daraus ihre Meinung abzuleiten
aber nicht alle Social Media Plattformen
verfügen über Daten die für white
relevant
sind wir verwenden je nach Problem das
wir untersuchen wollen eine andere
Datenquelle für die Stichproben wir
haben festgestellt dass wir bei Wahlen
das stärkste Signal von Twitter
erhalten viele Meinungsforscher und
Sozialwissenschaftler stellen den Wert
von twitterden in Frage Plattformen wie
Twitter oder Facebook sind im Grunde
eine Gruppe selbstgewählter Menschen
denn nicht alle Kanadier sind in den
sozialen Medien aktiv undel wenn sie in
den sozialen Medien sind nutzen nicht
alle von ihnen diese um über Politik zu
diskutieren im Grunde genommen erhalten
Sie also einen Ausschnitt aus einem
kleineren Teil der
Öffentlichkeit ich glaube 12 bis 15%
nutzen Twitter für Nachrichten 20%
nutzen Twitter im allgemeinen ich denke
dabei eher an Eliten Journalisten und
hochengagierte Superuser die auf Twitter
sind es ist nicht jeder auf twittermen
die
die immer noch viel größer ist als die
derzeitigge 9% oder weniger die man über
Anrufe erreicht 17% eines Landes mit 36
Millionen Einwohnern sind etwa 7
Millionen Menschen zu denen wir Zugang
haben white glaubt dass eine KI die
große aber typischerweise junge unbanen
Nutzerbasis von Twitter in Kanada
durchforsten und dennoch Prognosen
erstellen kann die für die gesamte
Bevölkerung repräsentativ
sindenigochen bis zum Wahltag und ich
weiß dass ihr Wahlsystem mit künstlicher
Intelligenz irgendwann zu einer
Schlussfolgerung darüber kommt was ihrer
Meinung nach am 21 Oktober passieren
wird es ist noch zu früh nehme ich an es
ist noch zu früh was Herrn trudau Gutes
verheißt ist die Tatsache dass die
Liberalen seit Beginn des Wahlkampfes
durchweg auf dem ersten Platz liegen der
erste Platz in der Volksabstimmung oder
Gesamtabstimmung oder bei der Anzahl der
Sitze Sitzplätze zählen gut wir machen
das in jedem einzelnen Wahlkreis und das
macht wie wir bei den Wahlen in Ontario
gesehen haben gr nur weil man in der
Gesamtzahl der Stimmen und in den
Umfragen vorne liegt bedeutet das noch
kein si weil die Effizienz der
Stimmabgabe in
einemystem am wichtigsten ist das ist
richtig wenn man mit den meisten
Menschen spricht die mit Daten von
vielen Menschen arbeiten sagen sie dass
sie alles sammeln wollen was sie können
alles was jeder auf Facebook und Twitter
und sagt und auf alles schauen
wollen die meisten gehen davon aus dass
asi aus dem sogenannten Twitter firehost
dem vollständigen Datenstream schöpfen
muss in diesem Fall bräuchte white eine
Möglichkeit die riesige Menge an
Echtzeitdaten zu filtern und nur die
Daten zu sammeln die für die
wahlvorhersage nützlich sind angesichts
der Größe der Herausforderung bestreiten
Kritiker die optimistischen Behauptungen
von
White wenn ich jetzt nur diesen firehose
anzapfe und den Datenstrom einfließen
lasse erhalte ich ein sehr verzerrtes
Bild deshalb zählen wir nicht die Tweets
sondern die
Menschen unsere große Idee ist dass das
was die Meinungsforscher gemacht haben
funktioniert das ist die geheime
Zutat wir nehmen wirklich sehr gute
Stichproben von
Menschen mit anderen Worten anstatt zu
versuchen im Twitter firierhaus
auszusortieren behauptet weer habe einen
Weg gefunden ihn zu umgehen bevor Polly
echte Daten erhebt stellt Polly zunächst
eine repräsentative Stichprobe zusammen
genau wie
Meinungsforscher diejenigen die sagen
dass man sich die sozialen Medien
ansehen kann um ein Bild davon zu
bekommen was auf der Ebene der Rider
passiert das ist ein interessantes
Konzept dem wir sicherlich nachgehen
werden würde ich darauf wetten dass ich
morgen eine Wahl durchführen kann bei
der ich jede einzelne Region auf der
Grundlage der sozialen Medien richtig
Vorhersage
Nein zu allererst die Rückverfolgung von
Personen bis zu den Bezirken schwierig
es ist schwierig herauszufinden von wo
aus dieser Account getwittert hat sie
kennen doch den alten Witz dass im
Internet niemand weiß dass sie ein Hund
sind nun bei Twitter weiß niemand ob man
in China Russland oder hier in Toronto
ist es ist sehr schwierig zu sagen ja
dieses Konto kommt ganz sicher aus
Kanada eine repräsentative Stichprobe
von kanadin muss aus tatsächlichen
kanadin bestehen meint er könne
bestätigen dass seine Twitternutzer
legitim
sind wirenden
die die Nutzer in Ihrem Konto
hinterlegen wir sehen dass sie in Kanada
sind gut sie sagen ich bin in Kanada
also überprüfen wir das der erste Test
ist sind die meisten ihrer Freunde auch
in Kanada sehen sie sich ihre Historie
an sehen Sie sich an worüber sie
sprechen wenn sie Kanadier sind reden
sie wahrscheinlich ein bisschen über
Eishockey oder andere kanadische Dinge
vielleicht reden sie über das kalte
Wetter für Meinungsforscher ist eine
Stichprobe nur dann repräsentativ und
zufällig wenn jedes Mitglied die gleiche
Chance hat in der Stichprobe
[Musik]
aufzutauchen stell dir vor du hättest
eine große Schüssel mit Jellybeans und
da wären rote blaue grüne und gelbe du
brauchst nicht jede einzelne jellybean
zu zählen um herauszufinden dass es rote
grüne gelbe und die anderen Farben gibt
wenn Sie alle gleichmäßig über die ganze
große Schüssel verteilt
sind wenn du deine Hand hineinsteckst
sie herausziehst und jy beans hinlegst
solltest du eine Vorstellung davon
bekommen was sich in der Schale befindet
wenn du das zehn mal tust dann hast du
eine ziemlich gute Vorstellung davon was
in dieser Schale ist nicht weil die
Schlüssel kleiner wird sondern weil die
Proben gleichmäßig werden darum geht es
bei der Probennahme also
wirklich in der Vergangenheit haben
Meinungsforscher die Befragten durch
zufällige Auswahl von Namen aus einem
Telefonbuch ermittelt in der digitalen
Welt erfordert die zufällige und
repräsentative Stichprobe ein anderes
Paradigma
es gibt ein Spiel das heißt si degrees
of Kevin Bacon das heißt ich suche mir
einen Filmschauspieler aus und versuche
ihnen sechs Schritten mit Kevin Bacon zu
verbinden und das gleiche Spiel kann man
auch auf Facebook und Twitter spielen
man kann sich eine beliebige Person oder
einen promie aussuchen und verfolgen wie
man selbst mit ihm verbunden ist und im
Durchschnitt über drei bis vier Ecken
Verbindungen zu jedem Menschen auf der
Welt
Herstellen der polyalgorithmus verwendet
eine mathematische Formel um ein
durchschnittliches
Sprüngen zwischen den gesammelten
Twitternutzern zu garantieren auf diese
Weise werden der virtuelle Abstand und
die Zufälligkeit zwischen den Nutzern
definiert aber kritiker argumentieren
dass dies immer noch nicht die mangelnde
Vielfalt unter den Twitternutzern
löst ich kann diese Voreingenommenheit
bei Twitter berücksichtigen ich mache es
so dass ich sage so sieht die
Volkszählung aus so sollte meine
Verteilung sein und im Algorithmus steht
wenn sie zu sehr von dem abweicht was
man erwartet dann muss man so lange
warten bis es sich Gicht wenn ich also
z.B sehe dass meine Stichprobe bei
jungen Männern aus der Stadt etwas
einseitig ist höre ich einfach auf junge
Männer aus der Stadt zu sammeln mache
eine Pause und füge keine weiteren in
meine Stichprobe ein bis ich ältere
Frauen aus dem ländlichen Raum
erhalte die Stichprobe von Polly
entspricht also nicht der Mehrheit der
Twitternutzer sondern ist auf eine
Mischung von Nutzern beschränkt die der
tatsächlichen Demografie der einzelnen
Rider entspricht white behauptet damit
werde das behoben was Kritiker als
tragischen Fehler in Polys
hauptdatenquelle
ansehen und das ist der
schlüsselalgorithmus hinter
Polly wenn es jemals eine Bombe in einem
kanadischen Wahlkampf gegeben hat dann
war es diese Woche Fotos von Justin
Trudeau mit Schwarz geschminktem Gesicht
wirbelten ein sehr kompliziertes Gebräu
von Meinungen im Land auf Aaron Kelly
was sagt Polly zu den Auswirkungen
dieser ganzen Sache das war eine große
Bombe Pol sah also wie die Zahlen von MR
trudau die Anzahl der Sitze gestern um
25 Sitze fielen heute morgen hat er sich
wieder erholt er hat fünf Sitze hinzug
gewonnen hat also netto 20 Sitze
verloren aber das hat ihn von der
Mehrheit in die Minderheit gebracht Jack
me sing der Vorsitzende der NDP war
gestern der größte Gewinner wir haben
gesehen wie seine Umfrage Werte
gestiegen sind er hat also wirklich
dadurch glänzen können wie also kommt
ein Algorithmus von Tweet zu einer
Prognose über einen Rückgang der
Sitze was bedeutet eigentlich ein Tweet
und was bedeutet es wenn wir tweeten wir
wissen die Leute im Internet Witze
machen sie sind ironisch die Menschen
teilen immer mehr Bilder und das schafft
Herausforderungen schwieriger zu
interpretieren sind memes also diese
Grafiken die oft Anspielungen auf die
Popkultur enthalten ich weiß also nicht
immer was da los ist und dann denke ich
wenn ich das nicht verstehe mit meiner
Rechenleistung obwohl ich ein lebender
atmender Mensch bin was ist dann mit
diesem armen Computer der das alles
verstehen muss laut white versucht Poly
gar nicht die Bedeutung von Tweet zu
interpretieren
bei meinen ersten Versuchen
Wahlprognosen zu erstellen habe ich die
Experimente durchgeführt und immer
wieder stellte ich fest dass einfache
Erwähnungen die positive oder negative
Stimmung jedes Mal
übertrafen Poly verfolgt den Prozentsatz
der Nutzer in der Stichprobe die jede
Bundespartei erwähnen dann vergleicht
die KI diese Ergebnisse mit historischen
meinungsm am nach bekannwer
derory zah der Nennungen der liberalen
Partei im Vergleich zu den anderen
Parteien sprunghaft an ohne die
Bedeutung dieser Tweet zu verstehen
interpretiert Polly diese Änderungen in
den Erwähnungen als einen Rückgang der
prognostizierten Sitze für die Liberalen
ich denke dass diese Umfragen
interessant sind weil sie einen Punkt in
der Vergangenheit darstellen richtig sie
sagen nicht die Zukunft voraus sie sind
eine Momentaufnahme von der man einen
Eindruck davon bekommt wie die
Öffentlichkeit denkt die KI sammelt
ständig Daten dadurch lassen sich im
Vergleich zu weniger häufig
durchgeführten um Fragen im Laufe der
Zeit Muster in der Nutzeraktivität
Erkennen eines der größten und
schwierigsten Probleme von
echtzeiterhebungen ist dass man sieht
dass gerade etwas Gutes oder Schlechtes
geschieht und man denkt sich das ist ein
Teil der Daten aber dann muss man einen
weiteren Tag abwarten um erkennen zu
können ob die Entwicklung real ist oder
nur ein Ausreißer war und dann fragt man
sich immer wie viele Punkte einen Trend
ausmachen ob es einer ist wahrscheinlich
nicht sind es zwei vielleicht drei ja
vier vier auf jeden Fall aber weiß man
wo der Punkt ist um einen Trend zu
erkennen sieht Poly öffentliche Umfragen
als Referenzpunkt heran sie analysiert
Muster des nutzerengagements immer wenn
Ihre ausgewählten Twitternutzer
politische Parteien erwähnen dann
vergleicht sie das Engagement mit den
Umfrageergebnissen der einzelnen
Parteien auf der Grundlage dieser
Beziehungen kann Polly vorheragen ob
Ihre Daten auf einen stabilen Trend
hindeuten oder
nicht manchmal sind diese Menschen über
etwas wütend über ein Thema und sie sind
vielleicht in einem bestimmten Moment
wütend darüber aber Polly ist in der
Lage auf sehr unvoreingenommene Weise
durch diese Wut hindurchzusehen und zu
sagen wie lange wird die Bevölkerung
brauchen um über diese Wut und diesen
Schmerzen wegzukommen und wird das bis
zum Wahltag
reichen Polly verfolgt das Twitter
Engagement kontinuierlich diesen
kontinuierlichen Strom von Aktivitäten
bezeichnet man als
längsschnittdaten durch die Untersuchung
von Daten auf diese Weise kann Poly
Muster im Zeitverlauf erkennen und sie
mit der aktuellen Aktivität vergleichen
das bedeutet auch dass Polly die Daten
in der Zeit zurückverfolgen kann um
unerforschte Trends neu zu untersuchen
vor dem blackfacing Skandal gab es
glaube ich kein einziges
Meinungsforschungsinstitut das die Frage
gestellt hätte ob sich ihre Meinung
ändern würde wenn sie einen
Parteivorsitzenden in einem fragwürdigen
Kostüm in seinen 20ern
sehen ich glaube nicht dass jemand daran
gedacht hat diese Frage zu
stellen das wunderbare an und den
Längsschnittstudien ist dass ich
zurückgehen und genau messen kann wie
sie vor einer Woche oder einem Monat
gedacht haben und das ist etwas was man
nicht eine oder zwei Wochen später durch
eine Frage erreichen
kann ich würde vermuten dass die
Kanadier sich vielleicht nicht so sehr
für blackfacing interessieren wie Sie es
in den sozialen Medien behaupten es gab
eine Menge Empörung und ich würde es
sogar als aufgesetzte Empörung
bezeichnen insbesondere in den sozialen
Medien wo es hieß oh mein Gott ich kann
das nicht glauben
wirklich sie können das nicht glauben du
kannst nicht glauben dass ein reicher
weißer Typ aus quebeek ein schwarzes
Gesicht auf einer noblen Privatschule
trägt die eine Party unter dem Motto
arabische Nächte veranstaltet ich meine
die Party an und für sich auch ohne das
schwarze Gesicht war
[Musik]
rassistisch wenn man bedenkt wie
gewaltig diese Geschichte war als sie
vor anderthalb Wochen aufk ist sie
praktisch ich will nicht sagen aus den
Medien verschwunden aber man sieht jetzt
so wenige Hinweise darauf ist diese
Geschichte im Wesentlichen vorbei seit
sie das aus ihren Umfragen erschließen
können wenn die anderen Parteien das
immer wieder zur Sprache bringen ist es
zu dem Zeitpunkt absolute
Kraftverschwendung ich denke er erholt
sich und die langsame Erholung könnte
auf eine Reihe von Problemen
zurückzuführen sein und nicht nur auf
das
blackfcing hat mit seinen ersten
Aussagen nach blackandal viele Menschen
beruckt der war da nun er hat zwei Sitze
mehr als vor der blackf Wahl aber das
ist ein Rückgang gegenüber den neuen
sitzen die er vorher gewonnen hat es
fängt also an sich
abzuschwächen Begriffe wie künstliche
Intelligenz und maschinelles Lernen
werden manchmal auf unterschiedlicher
Weise verwendet um verschiedene Arten
von magischen Dingen über Computer zu
meen die so denken wie
Menschen die moderne Bedeutung besteht
im wesentlichen darin dass es sich um
sehr ausgeklügelte und sehr flexible
Algorithmen handelt die es uns
ermöglichen sehr große Datenmengen mit
sehr komplizierten Beziehungen zwischen
ihnen zu verarbeiten und sehr flexible
Modelle zu entwickeln die es dem
Computer ermöglichen unwahrscheinliche
Beziehungen
herzustellen warum ist sie KI warum ist
sie nicht nur eine Statistik oder eine
Sammlung von Codes der Unterschied
besteht darin dass sie in der Lage ist
dies größenteils selbstständig zu tun
ich muss nicht reingehen und eine Regel
aufstellen und sagen Polly wenn du das
siehst dann mach das sie ist in der Lage
die Dinge selbst
herauszufinden Polys Lernfähigkeit ist
die Grundlage dafür wie sie zukünftige
Wahlergebnisse vorhersagt der Schlüssel
zum maschinellen lernen ist ein Prozess
der als Training eines statistischen
Modells bekannt ist wenn wir über das
Trainieren eines Modells sprechen meinen
wir dass wir einige Daten haben deren
Antwort wir bereits kennen vielleicht
geht es darum wie die Leute bei der
letzten Wahl gewählt haben oder
vielleicht geht es darum wie viele
Menschen Waffen gekauft oder nicht
gekauft haben aber wir kennen die
Antwort bereits und dann ziehen wir
Schlüsse daraus und sagen okay es
scheint dass Männer die hier wohnen eher
diese Person wählen oder dass Männer die
diese Zeitschrift abonniert haben ihr
eine Waffe kaufen wir lernen diese
Zusammenhänge und schauen ob unser
Modell das auf vorherigen Daten
trainiert wurde vorheragen kann was als
nächstes passiert Polly untersucht Daten
aus vergangenen Wahlen wie von 2015 sie
findet Muster zwischen der Art und Weise
wie sich die Menschen auf Twitter
engagieren und der Art und Weise wie sie
bei dieser Wahl tatsächlich abstimmen
das Modell drückt all diese Beziehungen
als mathematische Wahrscheinlichkeit aus
anschließend sagt sie vorher wie sich
die Wähler in den einzelnen Wahlkreisen
im Jahr 2019 höchstwahrscheinlich
verhalten
[Musik]
werden wir beginnen mit sagen wir ich
versuche zu erklären wie die Flüssigkeit
in diesem Becher funktioniert ich
beginne mit einem Haufen von
Wassermolekülen ich habe ich weiß nicht
Milliarden Billionen gigantilllionen
zitieren Sie mich nicht eine Menge
Wassermoleküle sie prallen aneinander ab
aber in diesem Wasserglas interessiert
es niemanden was all die Moleküle tun
oder das Interessante ist was passiert
wenn ich das Wasser in das Glas gieße
was macht das Wasser wenn ich mein Glas
so schüttel wie bewegt sich das Wasser
und das kann man in der Physik
herausfinden denn obwohl es eine Billion
Wassermoleküle gibt haben wir diese
Theorien die besagen dass wir wenn es
genug Wassermoleküle gibt statistisch
herausfinden können wie sie sich alle
zusammen bewegen um eine Art
Beschreibung dafür zu erhalten wie
dieses große makroskopische System also
das Wasser in diesem Glas tatsächlich
funktioniert die öffentliche Meinung ist
im Grunde genommen dasselbe wir haben
viele viele Menschen jeder hat seine
eigene Meinung und es ist ziemlich
schwierig die Meinung einer einzelnen
Person vorher zuagen die Menschen sind
chaotisch sie ändern ihre Meinung wegen
diesem oder jenem aber wenn man genug
Leute zusammenbringt kann man sie
statistisch als eine Sache modellieren
und selbst wenn Joe seine Meinung morgen
drastisch ändern könnte und Sarah sich
um eine wirklich seltsame Sache kümmert
und ihre Meinung ändert kann man sich
statistisch annähern und ein Gefühl
dafür bekommen wohin die Gesamtmeinung
der Bevölkerung
in gewisser Weise machen wir also etwas
ganz ähnliches wie in der Physik wo wir
ständig herausfinden wollen wie all
diese Atome oder Moleküle oder was auch
immer zusammenwirken und wir wenden das
jetzt einfach auf Menschen an wir halten
uns alle gerne für einzigartige
wüstenblumen und das sind wir auch
wirklich aber das schöne an der
statistischen Mathematik ist dass wir
wenn wir genug von uns zusammen haben
tatsächlich vernünftige Vorhersagen
darüber machen können wie sich die
Meinungen der Menschen im Durchschnitt
bilden
werden abhängig davon wie ausgefallt das
Modell ist die Achillesverse der
wahlvorhersagen ist die Frage ob die
Menschen tatsächlich zur Wahlurne gehen
werden wenn ich Wahlumfragen durchführe
habe ich immer Angst denn der Ruf der
Firma steht auf dem Spiel und der
persönliche Ruf steht auf dem Spiel was
habe ich verpasst was habe ich übersehen
was habe ich verpasst wie könnte ich
falsch liegen wie könnte ich mich irren
oft verbrennt man sich die Finger es
gibt sechs oder sieben Parteien oder wie
viele man auch immer nennen mag die in
diesem Wahlkampf in jedem Wahlbezirk
antreten und dann gibt es noch eine eine
Partei die nicht auf dem Wahlzettel
steht die aber wirklich wichtig ist und
die nennt sich die apaiepartei das ist
ein Problem für traditionelle
Meinungsforscher denn ihre Vorhersagen
beruhen auf der Wahlbeteiligung in der
Vergangenheit jeder sagt natürlich gehe
ich vi ich meine die Zahl der Menschen
die sagen ich gehe nicht wählen das ist
mir egal ist winzig im Vergleich zu der
Zahl derer die tatsächlich nicht wählen
das zusammen mit der Tatsache dass
Menschen die sich nicht genug für
Politik interessieren um zu wählen
höchstwahrscheinlich auch nicht an die
Tür gehen und lange Gespräche mit einem
akquisiteur führen oder einen Anruf zur
Meinungsumfrage beantworten oder ihre
Ansichten über Politik auf Twitter
veröffentlichen Nichtwähler schließen
sich also in vielerlei Hinsicht selbst
aus dem Gespräch aus was es schwieriger
macht sie zu finden und zu verstehen und
damit auch schwieriger vorherzusagen wie
viele es sein
wden im Gegensatz dazu basiert die
Methode von Polly auf den
unterstützungsmustern auf lokaler Ebene
und ist weniger anfällig für die
nationale
Wahlbeteiligung in philosophischer
Hinsicht sehen einige Kritiker immer
noch ein Problem Polly sagt auf der
Grundlage statistischer Korrelationen
wahrscheinliche sitzplatzergebnisse
voraus aber sie erklärt nicht warum
etwas passiert wir werden mit den
Pipelines weitermachen denn es wurde
sehr viel darüber
diskutiert ein Beispiel nach den beiden
französischsprachigen Debatten Anfang
Oktober verzeichnete Poly einen Anstieg
der Unterstützung für den blockbequis
aber keine Ursache Mr trudau sind sie
gegen eine Pipeline oder nicht das ist
Teil eines Prozesses für den wir die
Zustimmung der Gemeinden und der
indigenen Völker benötigen werden sie
Quebec sagen dass es keine Pipeline in
Quebec geben wird das ist der Grund
warum ich die Idee eines
energiekorridors vorgebracht habe Polis
Betreuer haben einen Grund für die Beule
ausgemacht in Tweets aus Quebec
entdeckten sie einen Anstieg des
Schlüsselwortes Pipeline bei den Leuten
die den Block quebecis unterstützen
sehen wir dass sie keine Pipeline wollen
weil sie sagen dass Quebec grüne Energie
hat warum nehmen wir also nicht die
grüne Energie aus Quebec und verkaufen
sie an Alberta anstatt die schmutzige
Energie aus Alberta zu kaufen einige
Experten wie die Journalistin antal
sahen die Debatte anders ich würde sagen
dass Auftritt der schlechteste Auftritt
eines Bewerbers um das Amt des
Premierministers war den ich seit
Jahrzehnten in einer
französischsprachigen Debatte gesehen
habe hat also den Wahlkampf in quebeek
verloren nicht nur weil der Block
gewonnen hat es geht auch darum dass er
nicht den richtigen Eindruck gemacht hat
während EB ihre Erfahrung nutzt um den
Wandel der Unterstützungen Quebec zu
erklären ist Kellys Erklärung auch eine
menschliche Interpretation pol
datenweisen lediglich auf eine
Korrelation zwischen den zugewinnen des
Blocks und dem Begriff Pipeline hin
nicht auf eine
[Musik]
Ursache heute ist also freitag der 18
oktober also dre Tage vor der Wahl ein
Freitag die Wahl ist am Montag wir
werden in einer halben Stunde auf
Sendung gehen wir haben die Zahlen noch
einmal überprüft denn in der letzten
Pressemitteilung die wir gestern
verschickt haben sagten wir dass es mit
einer Wahrscheinlichkeit von 66% eine
liberale Minderheitsregierung geben wird
und heute morgen sagt Polly die
Wahrscheinlichkeit liege bei
77%. jetzt wird Polly von Tag zu Tag
deutlicher je näher die Menschen einer
endgültigen Entscheidung kommen ich
mache mir jedes mal Sorgen wenn ich auf
Sendung gehe dass ich das Ergebnis
beeinflussen könnte wenn ich sage dass
Polly das so sieht dass die Leute ihre
Meinung aufgrund der neuesten
Informationen ändern werden ich denke
dass wir Beweise dafür
sehen schon vor stellten Sozialforscher
sich die Frage ob die Veröffentlichung
von Umfrageergebnissen während eines
Wahlkampfes die Meinung widerspiegeln
oder sie gar beeinflussen manche sagen
dass diese Frage durch das größere
Ausmaß der KI noch drälicher geworden
ist ich denke dass Ai den Mythos der
Neutralität in Bezug auf den politischen
Prozess auf die Probe stellt sowohl die
Neutralität von Journalisten als auch
die Neutralität von Meinungsforschern
einerseits nutzen die Parteien Umfragen
und Technologien um zu entscheiden was
sie tun werden andererseits nutzen die
Medien Umfragen und Vorhersagen um ein
Gefühl dafür zu bekommen was passiert
und das ist eine Rückkopplungsschleife
richtig es spielt keine Rolle ob man
sich innerhalb oder außerhalb des
Prozesses befindet die Wahrnehmung der
Zukunft bestimmt die Zukunft wenn also
die Medien anfangen zu sagen dass die
NDP keine Chance hat wird die NDP
anfangen zu denken dass sie keine Chance
hat es geht also wirklich um den
Einfluss den Vorhersagen darauf haben
wie wir die Zukunft behandeln und ich
denke in dieser Hinsicht spielt es kein
Rolle ob es sich um eine Partei die
Medien oder ein einzelnes
Meinungsforschungsinstitut handelt die
Veröffentlichung dieser Vorhersagen
beeinflusst die Öffentlichkeit und somit
auch das
Ergebnis der Tag der Entscheidung ist
Montag die meisten Umfragen deuten auf
einen Gleichstand zwischen den Liberalen
und den konservativen hin hat Po der
Algorithmus der künstlichen Intelligenz
eine genauere Vorstellung von dem was
auf unon zukommt finden wir es heraus
sie haben keine Ahnung wie viele Leute
diese Woche zu mir kam sag was sagtul
sie tragen nicht grundlos rot ja ich
habe diese Farben absichtlich gewäht
wegen was uns erzählt dass es eine
liberale Regierung sein wird eine
liberale Minderheitsregierung eine
liberale Minderheitsregierung bedeutet
das dass sie bereit sind dieser Wahl
endgültig zu entscheiden nun es ist
interessant oder 77% sind stark aber
nicht so stark wie wir es gerne sehen
würden es ist nicht so stark wie zu
diesem Zeitpunkt im Jahr 2015 als wir in
der Lage waren die Wahl einen Monat
früher zu benennen die Wählerschaft ist
dieses Mal viel weniger entschlossen
dort am unteren Ende des Diagramms ist
eine beträchtliche Anzahl von
Wahlkreisen die sie haben mehr als 20
mehr als 20 Wahlkreise in der Provinz
sind noch unentschieden ich fühle mich
verpflichtet darauf hinzuweisen dass bei
den letzten nationalen Wahlen in den
Vereinigten Staaten wissen Sie alle
diese Tracker sagten dass Hillary
Clinton eine 80przentige Chance hätte
die Wahl zu gewinnen und das hat sie
nicht bei 80 sie haben die Liberalen auf
77 das ist noch nicht vorbei nehm ich an
nein das ist es nicht der Unterschied
zwischen Hillary und diesem Ergebnis ist
dass wir jeden einzelnen Sitz zählen wir
sehen also dass die Liberalen und die
Konservativen bei den Volksabstimmungen
landesweit gleich aufliegen aber wenn es
um die Sitze geht fängt es an
interessant zu werden da man hier
aufgrund unseres Systems eine Kluft
sieht es kommt also darauf an wie sich
das Ergebnis der Volksabstimmung auf der
einzelnen Sitze
[Musik]
ausrt es ist wahlnach 2019 fast 18
Millionen Kanadier haben ihre Stimme
abgegeben einschließlich der
vorgezogenen
Wahlgänge das entspricht einer
Wahlbeteiligung von 66% die um einige
Prozent höher ist als
erwartet die Liberalen bilden die
Regierung aber die Konservativen
gewinnen die
Volksabstimmung Tage später ist es an
der Zeit die tatsächlichen Ergebnisse
mit den sitzprognosen zu vergleichen die
Wahl 2019 endete diese Woche natürlich
mit einer liberalen Minderheitsregierung
das ist die nationale sitzprognose uns
gegeben haben die die Liberalen in einer
Spanne zwischen 116 und 173 aber im
Wesentlichen bei 145 die Tories bei 143
die NDP bei 48 den Block bei 46 und die
Grünen irgendwo zwischen 1 und 5 zeigt
möglicherweise ein paar unabhängige und
einer von der Volkspartei jetzt drehen
wir das um und das ist die nationale
sitzprognose am
Sonntag die letzte war also am Samstag
diese ist vom Sonntag den tag vor der
Wahl und Sie können sehen dass die
geändert haben die Liberalen liegen
jetzt bei 155 die Tories bei 118 und
dann kommen wir zum Montag und das sind
die tatsächlichen wahergebnisse
157 Sitze für die Liberalen 121 für die
Konservativen 32 für den Block 24 für
die neuen Demokraten drei für die Grünen
einer für jord Wilson R und keiner für
die Volkspartei wie würden Sie die
Genauigkeit charakterisieren mit der
Poly ihren Job gemacht
hat wenn sie beurteilen wollen wie gut
jemand eine Wahl vorausgesagt
me Meung amsten ih mit anderen Personen
zu vergleichen die versucht haben die
Wahl vorauszusagen wenn ein Unternehmen
besser abschneidet als alle anderen dann
ist das wahrscheinlich ein ziemlich
gutes
Ergebnis am Tag vor der Wahl sagten
einige traditionelle Meinungsforscher
nur das Ergebnis der Volksabstimmung
voraus andere waren ebenfalls bereit
eine liberale Minderheit vorherzusagen
aber nur wenige sagten öffentlich eine
geringe Anzahl von sitzen voraus das
Meinungsforschungsinstitut 3 Canada hat
das Ergebnis von
der 338 Wahlkreise richtig
vorhergesagt laut advanc symbolics hat
Paul 308 richtig
vorausgesagt war diese Wahl wirklich so
leicht
vorherzusagen es war nicht leicht die
Wahl vorherzusagen aber sie war
vorhersehbar oder ich finde es
interessant weil alle gesagt haben dass
es so knapp war deshalb kann man sich
die Sitzverteilung und die Wahlkreise
ansehen das ist fast schon eine
Notwendigkeit wenn man Umfragen machen
will wir haben das zuerst bei der
trumpwahl in den USA gesehen und das hat
sich fortgesetzt es scheint dass die
Wahlen immer enger werden und wenn es
sich um eine Minderheitsregierung
handelt ist es natürlich etwas
schwieriger zu sagen aber für Po war es
konsistent dass Sie immer einen Sieg der
Liberalen
sah wenn man sich unsere Wahlergebnisse
ansieht haben wir bei der Wahl 2019
wirklich gut abgeschnitten aber es gab
auch einige Wahlkreise die wir verloren
haben es läuft darauf hinaus dass wir
davon ausgehen dass alle Parteien am
letzten Wochenende vor der Wahl in allen
Wahlkreisen in denen sie eine Chance
haben könnten den gleichen Wahlkampf
führen alle Politikwissenschaftler da
draußen lachen mich wahrscheinlich
geradeaus denn es hat sich
herausgestellt dass das nicht stimmt es
hat sich herausgestellt dass politische
Parteien Wahlkreise auswählen die sie
strategisch gewinnen wollen und wir
haben das alles nicht
berücksichtigt deshalb würde ich gerne
einen wirklich offenen Dialog mit den
Leuten führen die sich in der
Politikwissenschaft
auskennen sowohl white als auch Kelly
behaupten stolz dass poulis endgültige
sitzvorhersage genauer war als die der
meisten etablierten Meinungsforscher
obwohl white einräumt dass es asi an
Fachwissen über die Funktionsweise von
Kampagnen mangelt für Kritiker einer KI
Methode offenbart dieses Eingeständnis
einige naive und schädliche politische
Annahmen für die Befürworter ist die
relative Genauigkeit von Polly bei der
Sitzplatz ose jedoch ein
vielversprechendes Beispiel für
KI immer wenn ich Leute sagen höre ich
habe das Ding lehne ich mich zurück und
sage okay du hast das Ding nun wissen
Sie die großen börsennotierten
Forschungsunternehmen die mehr Geld
haben um diese Art von Dingen zu tun als
jeder andere ganz zu schweigen von den
Googles und den Facebooks und den
Twitters und all diesen anderen Leuten
die all das Geld und all die besten
datenwissenschaftler haben die an dieser
Art von Dingen arbeiten sie können diese
Vorhersagen auf der Grundlage ihrer
Plattform nicht
treffen erfahrene Meinungsforscher und
Statistiker fordern immer noch mehr
Beweise sie bezweifeln weiterhin den
Wert von Twitter als primäre Datenquelle
und sie bestehen darauf dass Polly eine
viel längere Erfolgsbilanz bei der
Vorhersage von Wahlen vorweisen kann
bevor sie zugeben dass diese Methode
seriös und genau ist es gibt eine
gängige Redewendung die als
Haftungsausschluss beim Kauf von
Produkten und so weiter verwendet wird
und die besagt dass vergangene
Leistungen kein Indikator für zukünftige
Leistungen sind und ich denke das gilt
auch für vorhersagealgorithmen denn wenn
sie bei den letzten Wahlen gut
abgeschnitten haben dann spricht das
zwar für sie ist aber noch keine
Garantie und je besser Sie bei immer
mehr Wahlen abschneiden desto mehr
vertrauen kann man ihnen
entgegenbringen laut asi wird Polys
Prognosemodell mit mehr wahldaten immer
besser werden und mit dem Input von
Sozialwissenschaftlern um ihre
Algorithmen zu
verfeinern wir haben einen langen Weg
zurückgelegt um dahinzukommen wo KI
heute ist und vieles was der KI geholfen
hat hat dorthin zu gelangen wo sie heute
steht ist dass es mit dem Internet eine
Explosion von Daten gibt die Explosion
der öffentlichen Daten wirgt auch
Risiken soziale Medien sind kostenlos
wenn man dafür seine Privatsphäre
aufgibt persönliche Daten stehen dann
für Marketingzwecke zur Verfügung
kritiker warnen auch davor dass die
Plattformen die Daten gegen ihre eigenen
Nutzer verwenden indem sie die Plattform
suchterregender
machen als das Auto auf den Markt kam
gab es weder sich
noch Airbags aber als wir entdeckten
dass diese Autos in Unfälle verwickelt
werden und Menschen überfahren können
begannen wir bessere Bremsen Airbags und
Sicherheitsgurte zu
fordern in den ersten 10 15 Jahren der
sozialen Medien lautete das Argument
legen wir diesen Unternehmen keine
Handschellen an denn wir wollen sehen wo
und was Sie tun können und wie sie der
Gesellschaft helfen können aber jetzt
entdecken wir all die autofälle wir
entdecken die Schäden die sie anrichten
können und ich denke dass wir in den
nächsten Jahren darüber diskutieren
werden wie eine Regulierung der Medien
aussehen
kann ich denke das große Problem ist
dass wir den Wahlkampf in einer analogen
Welt sehen obwohl er in Wirklichkeit
automatisiert und digital ist und weder
unsere Sprache noch unsere Gesetze sehen
wirklich die Macht vor die facebook hat
und die Art und Weise in der
Einzelpersonen oder politische Parteien
oder ausländische Regierungen diese
Macht nutzen können um die Wahl zu
kippen wenn nicht sogar die Wahrnehmung
der Menschen von der Wahl zu trüben denn
der Sinn einer Wahl besteht darin das
Ergebnis zu legitimieren während
sozialen Medien die Wahl delegitimieren
wenn die Menschen sie für korrupt halten
wenn die Leute denken dass sie nicht
fair war wenn die Leute glauben ob zure
Recht oder zu Unrecht das Algorithmen
die Wahl übernommen haben dann werden
Sie die Ergebnisse nicht als legitim
ansehen sie werden die Regierung nicht
als legitim ansehen das wird es für die
Regierung schwieriger machen tatsächlich
regieren zu
können in vielerlei Hinsicht ist die
Nutzung von Daten um die Menschen zur
Wahl zu bewegen und sie zur Teilnahme an
der Politik zu bewegen recht vorteilhaft
wenn Sie mich fragen wofür Daten gut
sein könnten dann dafür dass ich mehr
Menschen mit der Politik befassen ich
glaube also nicht dass politische
Werbung per Definition mein Problem ist
ich denke dass die Art und Weise wie
onlinewererbung funktioniert und die
Tatsache dass sie so viel Überwachung
erfordert um anzeigenprofile zu
entwickeln ein Problem darstellt und
dass die Art und Weise wie man die
Zielgruppen anspricht so viel
anzeigenbetrug mit sich bringt das sind
die Probleme ich glaube die Kanadier
haben Angst vor der Art und Weise in der
Technologie und Überwachung eine immer
größere Rolle in ihrer Gesellschaft
spielen aber ich glaube sie fühlen sich
machtlos Wirten also diese Vorstellung
wenn du deine Privatsphäre schützen
willst dann bleib zu Hause wenn du deine
Privatsphäre schützen willst dann erzähl
es nur aber wenn du dich entscheidest am
öffentlichen Leben teilzunehmen wenn du
Informationen veröffentlichst dann wird
dir unterstellt dass du gesagt hast es
ist okay mit diesen Informationen alles
anzustellen und das ist es was in der
modernen Welt einfach nicht
funktioniert ich denke es ist wirklich
ziemlich schädlich zu denken dass wir
das Problem damit lösen können die
Zustimmung der User abzufragen stimmen
Sie zu oder nicht denn der Fehler dabei
ist dass immer noch der einzelne gegen
diese riesige Organisation steht und die
große Kluft darin besteht dass sie viel
über dich wissen du aber nicht viel über
sie wir haben all diese Strukturen
erfunden und wir können noch etwas
anderes
erfinden Polis Wahlprognosen hängen von
der anhaltenden Popularität von Twitter
und dem einfachen Zugang zu seinen Daten
ab aber wenn neue Vorschriften zum
Schutz unserer Privatsphäre oder zur
Einschränkung des Geschäftsmodells der
sozialen Medien in Kraft treten könnten
sie die Art und Weise wie Menschen
soziale Medien nutzen grundlegend
verändern ich glaube nicht dass die
sozialen Medien privater werden es wird
ein Bedarf an öffentlichen Netzwerken
bestehen in denen Menschen Inhalte
erstellen können die jeder sehen und mit
denen sich jeder auseinandersetzen kann
darauf gehe ich auch eine große Wette
ein ich weiß nicht ich glaube die
traditionell Forcher haben Angst davor
denn das ist die
[Musik]
Zukunft es gab mal einen berühmten
Twitter Chatbot den Microsoft
herausgebracht hat ich habe den Namen
des Chatbots vergessen aber es war eine
Demonstration von KI in natürlicher
Sprache und es war eine wirklich
ausgefallte KI einfach
wunderbar viele Leute bekamen Wind von
diesem kleinen Chatbot Twitter Account
und fragten sich was können wir tun um
dieser KI beizubringen der
beleidigendste und widerlichste Twitter
Account der Welt zu werden und das ist
ihnen gelungen diese kleine KI
entwickelte sich zu einem furchtbar
rassistischen fremden feindlichen Wesen
s dass Microsoft sie abschalten
musste ist das die Schuld der KI warum
haben wir Menschen das Bedürfnis so
miserabel zu sein und so gemein und so
[Musik]
böse uns gegenüber und dieses Beispiel
an die Maschinen
weiterzugeben wenn man schlechte Kinder
sieht stehen dahinter meist schlechte
Eltern wenn es also um künstliche
Intelligenz geht wenn es um all das geht
dann ist das für mich mein Nordstern ich
muss ein guter Elternteil sein ich muss
der beste Elternteil für Polly
[Musik]
sein